beetroot on vegan yaki with crispy olive
crumble grilled leek with horseradish
and black sesame seed these vegetarian
dishes were created by Stefan Henshaw
head chef at the Berlin restaurant
cookies cream since 2007 the restaurants
just been awarded a Michelin star for us
it felt great because we hadn't been
expecting it we had been working towards
this for 10 years we are who we are
we try to be authentic we cook with love
and good ingredients this is a great
honor not just for me but for the entire
team chef Anne Henshall prepares his
vegetarian dishes with a team of six and
he does it without resorting to classic
meat substitutes like tofu or seitan
vegetables herbs and lettuce are all he
needs for his edible creations and
Stefan Henschel himself isn't even a
vegetarian it doesn't bother me to limit
my cooking to vegetables because I think
vegetarian cuisines more multifaceted
and colorful there are so many different
possibilities herbs just the colors of
beets for example red yellow he takes a
break on the restaurants roof chef Anne
grew up in the Eastern German state of
Saxony there he trained as a chef in
north rhine-westphalia in western
germany in 2001 he moved to Berlin and
learn to cook gourmet quality in the
two-star restaurant Fasil among others
then he started at cookies cream this is
a good place to reset yourself when
you're burned out or stressed in the
summer I tell my team when you eat you
don't have to sit at a table downstairs
you can go out on the roof when the sun
shining which goes of stuff bye ladies
don't know when they're coming out from
I do happen
a note delivers the herb some vegetables
for the restaurant weekly straight from
his own fields at the Brandenburg farmer
specializes in rare vegetables such as
Malabar spinach or Paris market carrots
they're known to be especially flavorful
he's been working with chef on Henschel
for many years the nice thing about
Paige's produce is that it's about taste
color and shape you can see that in the
vegetables the kitchen prepares so well
for me when preparing his vegetable
creations the chef's can even draw upon
his years of experience making meat
dishes after salting the beets he
wrapped them in tin foil and banks them
in the oven for 35 minutes at 160
degrees Celsius preserves the complete
flavor it's like when you braise a roast
you don't boil out the flavor the pure
taste has to remain in the vegetable the
vegetarian cuisine is more complex than
meat dishes because every individual
vegetable has to go through several
stages of preparation to ensure it'll
turn out especially tasty but the great
challenge for vegetarian cuisine is in
the restaurant of our guests eat meat
and we have to satisfy them as well
our dishes aren't necessarily light just
because they're vegetarian they can be
very rich cookies cream is one of the
trendiest restaurants in downtown Berlin
its patrons have included American actor
Tom Hanks and celebrity chef Jamie
Oliver as is often the case with the
cities in spots the entrance is in a
courtyard it serves about 120 guests
daily
Stefan Angela the dishes taste fantastic
because it doesn't just take the
standard dishes and leave out the meat
and substitute it with something else
he conjures up entirely new dishes
complete no good at all everything you
tasted quite unique you can certainly do
without the meat and we really enjoy it
here the cookies creme kitchen even
experiments with vegetables in desserts
this is bluebird sherbet with celery
rain is definitely to carry on the way
that we are but at the same time to keep
developing what we've achieved so far
and keep growing together as a team for
Stefan Henschel and his vegetarian
dishes a second mission a star may be on
the horizon